يبدو ان هناك احتمالا كبيرا ان تكون شيرين
بعقله قد اصيبت عن طريق الخطا بنران جيش
الافاق
[موسيقى]
اسعاف
العادل الامريكيه ابلغت نظيرتها
الاسرائيليه بفتح مكتبه التحقيق الفيدرالي
تحقيقا في مقتل الزميله شيرين ابو عقله لن
يتم تحقيق مع جنود الجيش الاسرائيلي على
يد الاف بي اي ولا على يد اي جهه اجنبيه
مهما كانت تعتبر صديقه لن نتخلى عن جنودنا
لتحقيقات غريبه احتجاجنا الحاد على ذلك
ارسل للجانب الامريكي عبر القنوات
الملائمه
خلال الاشهر الماضيه السته الماضيه
قابلنا شهود عيان كانوا موجودين وسجلوا
ونظرنا في فيديوهات جديده مصوره من نقاط
مختلفه تبين ما حصل نحن نشدد على ان
المدعي العام ليس عليه ان ينظر فقط في
الاشخاص الذين شاركوا بشكل مباشر باطلاق
النار بل ايضا من كانوا في القياده واعطوا
الاوامر